hello guys it's silver art again and
since I finished this coaster it's time
for me to build a new coaster and this
new coaster is going to be a bnm inverts
because I just felt like this would be
the perfect opportunity to make a BM
terrain hugging invert like nemesis I
really like doing those things I don't
know why but I just like them and I just
felt that I really needed one in this
park and it would be an opportunity for
me to do lots of crazy rock work like I
did in here but mix it with a lot of
scenery and ridiculous awesomeness and
just in general I've always been a fan
of or the bnm inverts with a lot of
scenery interaction like Spitfire and
that Jake and I made but my favorite
roller coaster 3 roller coaster ever is
probably arm Potter and that was also
being I'm inverts so I'm just going to
try this and see if I can come up with
something cool but the thing here is
that I'm going to build the coaster
first and then I'm going to build the
scenery so the rock work the path work
the buildings everything around the
coaster just so I can come up with a
perfect layout without any problems and
I can later on make some scenery around
it so I have some nice interaction with
that so I'm going to start that right
now well it's safe to say that this is
not going well right now because I'm
very happy actually with the first part
and it's kind of like this flying
coaster you can really see that the
mountain is going to be over here and
then there's going to be path walks over
here just to have a nice view of the
coaster but then the problem is this
lower area I wanted to divide the
coaster into parts where where you'd
have the high mountain area over here
and like a valley of some sort over
there but the problem I have right now
is I've been busy for two hours trying
to get a good layout but it's really
hard to get nice layout over here that
isn't repeating and stuff that happened
over here and also to make sure that the
coaster doesn't drag on and then there's
the problem there I'll I shouldn't use
too much space for this because of
course I'm going to have other things
as well and the path is going to be
going over here and I would like to have
an attraction of some sorts over there
so yeah I'm kind of struggling with that
so I'm just going to try out a few
things you know right now okay so we're
have set a half an hour later and I had
this blended idea to make this right go
around the little island in the middle
of the lake so right now this right
almost covers the entire perimeter of
the park so that's kind of ridiculous
but whenever it's it's kind of
ridiculous park anyway because steampunk
medieval and epic rides that's basically
what I'm going for you know I'm not
trying to be too realistic I'm just
trying to make kind of a terrine park
sort of thing but right now the hardest
job is still left for me to do which is
connect this thing to the station so
that's going to be kind of hard
especially since this part over here
around the loop will be underground and
I'll have a path go or over that so yeah
kind of hard but I think I'll get there
we feel if your
I can let this go
you know
so you know by the looks this ride is
actually turning into a pretty cool
right I haven't named it yet I'm
debating whether I should call it code
zero or Jaeger or something else but I
kind of like the look of this of course
I still need to do foliage and some more
detailed rock work but I don't want to
bother with that
yet I want to finish the path work over
here first have the station done and of
course I still need to do rock work for
this entire section coaster so I'm far
from finished but I think this is enough
for today so I'm going to continue on
this next episode of this let's play so
Tillman